hi my name is Baba shiv I'm a professor
of marketing at The Graduate School of
Business
[Music]
when it comes to our communication many
of us make a fundamental mistake we
start from the wrong place we start by
saying this is what I want to say rather
than thinking about what our audience
needs to hear
as it depends out most of our
stakeholders are drawn to examples that
is why people buy lottery tickets even
though the actual probability of women
Lottery is extremely low there's a
famous saying here in Silicon Valley
that if you're a startup founder going
to an investor for money
you're going to get advice you go for
advice you're going to get money so what
you do is that go to this stakeholder
you're trying to influence you're trying
to get a buy-in from and what you do is
seek advice the person will provide
advice now that person's brain has
gotten invested in your idea now your
idea will become that person's baby as
well
[Music]
as a leader with a coherent strategy you
have a method to your Madness
your strategy is your unique way of
connecting the dots whenever you ask
someone to accomplish a specific
objective always help them see how it
fits into the bigger story when it comes
to making decisions about other people
those can be immensely consequential
they can relate to their livelihood to
their sense of Worth to their
psychological well-being we can't take
those lightly
[Music]
here are a few things we tell our
students about how to de-risk your humor
first don't ask will this make me sound
funny instead ask how will this make
other people feel
which also means never punching down
that is making fun of someone of lower
status and be sure to check your
distance how close are you personally to
what you're making light of I can make
fun of my mother but not Jennifer's
mother
who by the way I hear is a saint she is
Saint a lovely woman
my mom once said in a class and at the
end of the class he said to me uh Amir I
have no idea what you said but you're a
genius
start taking humor seriously seriously
seriously I'm not and I disagree on
everything no Rob you're wrong we don't
disagree on everything we're growing
many things actually okay eventually yes
we do end up agreeing on everything
[Music]